i got a whole bunch of emails and tweets
and messages from people wanting me to
talk about this
so let's do it tesla has purchased a
billion and a half dollars
in bitcoin and we learned this on monday
morning thanks to an sec filing that
tesla did
1.5 million dollars in bitcoin i'm sorry
1.5 billion
dollars in bitcoin have been purchased
by tesla
and tesla also has announced that they
will start accepting bitcoin
as a payment method for its products
we've sort of followed
uh tesla ceo elon musk's comments about
cryptocurrency
in the past uh sometimes his comments
and tweets about cryptocurrency will
actually
move crypto markets and that along with
the fact that
tesla already is uh continuing to
dominate
electric car market share makes this a
particularly interesting
decision the official reason that tesla
gives for
why they both bought the the bitcoin and
plan to accept it
is that they quote want more flexibility
to further diversify and maximize
returns on our cash and they will be
accepting bitcoin quote subject to
applicable laws
and initially on a limited basis this
would make tesla the first
major automaker to accept bitcoin for
payment so as many of you might know
i have both been a tesla shareholder for
many many years
and have held bitcoin for many many
years so i'm going to give you
sort of like my personal take on what
i'm doing as a result of this in a
moment i do want to mention
this video is sponsored by policy genius
it's really important to have your life
insurance strategy
in place policy genius has made the
process
really really simple from start to
finish they make sure you're getting a
good deal
policy genius is not an insurance
company it's an insurance marketplace
you answer a few questions
they give you personalized quotes from
top life insurance companies you compare
prices in one place
you can get advice from policy genius
insurance
experts if you want it's free to use
they never sell your information
i went on policy genius took me two
minutes to find life insurance quotes
some of them were actually less
expensive than my current policy
you can save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius
that could work out to 1300 or more per
year and i'm sure that for a lot of
people watching
shopping for life insurance has been on
your to-do list for a while
just cross it off the list policy genius
makes it quick and easy
you know you're getting a fair price go
to policygenius.com
david pakman show shop save
etc all really good stuff so
um what am i doing with my tesla stock
and my bitcoin
as a result of this announcement from
tesla
uh that they have bought 1.5 billion
dollars in bitcoin
and will be accepting bitcoin initially
on a limited basis i am doing
absolutely nothing you all know
uh that i never give any investment
advice on the show
but i do tell you what i'm doing you all
if you've seen some of my segments on
that you know that my view
uh has been and continues to be i'm not
looking to gamble
i'm not doing short term trades i'm not
trying to day trade or look at technical
analysis or any of that stuff
um i bought both tesla stock and bitcoin
years and years ago in amounts that i
knew were speculative and could go to
zero
i don't buy on margin i don't short
anything i just buy and hold and wait
and that's all i'm going to continue to
do i'm not making any moves whatsoever i
think that
the electric car i mean listen these are
two industries that are not yet mature
we talk about you know people talk about
bitcoin they say it'll be worth zero
it'll be worth
a million dollars a coin i have no idea
uh it
is not an uh it's not a space that has
matured yet
electric cars uh we see tesla scooping
up tons of market share but more and
more automakers are now also making
electric car
offerings uh what would be the even
without accepting bitcoin what would be
the future of tesla's market
tesla's market share i have no idea with
so many new competitors with electric
vehicles
it's not clear to me um so my
approach has been and will continue to
be to
simply hold and i think that as the
electric
car industry continues to mature some
states already with plans to phase out
electric vehicles
2035 in california as one example some
other states and even other countries
putting in place different goals as far
as that goes i don't pretend to know
what the future of these industries is
or are
so i am simply going to continue waiting
but a very interesting announcement both
from the standpoint of tesla making a
move to make
their electric cars uh have something
that others don't which is the ability
to pay in bitcoin and
also to further establish bitcoin um
in the mainstream of american finance so
we're going to be following it i'm
curious to hear what you think
you can find me on twitter deepakman